good ball Oh [ __ ] kind of Wow
okay all right there that that that is
an awesome now it looks like handsome
Squidward mixed with it's all kinds of
disturbing what in the world how do we
even go
oh I hesitated and it didn't work on
that it's no time for that we gotta go
why is that poon twitching markiplier
spike falls you damn your mother Rashed
elephant nipples you are doesn't make
any sense
what are you trying to say to me oh wait
no wait I regret everything hope that
was enough speed uh-oh I got a my still
alive no that was loud as f this level
was just called markiplier hop okay Wow
Marga Blaire fails I don't know about
not do full powerful that is minutes
I'll just I'll kill myself before you
get a chance
welcome to throw no no no I don't want
to die no Marga Blair mine jump try to
land on the wood yeah oh that actually
Oh God okay I gotta go okay that's good
to hear I want to climb the wall to get
the key OOP I feel the texture let's
hope you feel the sudden you feel it it
was an important bonding moment in our
you have reached your destination this
is gonna be some five nights to Treasure
Island well okay I couldn't read it slow
stop
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks to get everyone and
as always I will see you in the next
video